and of course it's a rare day when we
don't mention a climate report on this
show from a big international
institution and more often than not
they're telling policymakers that
targets simply aren't enough that not
enough is being spent and they were
heading for climate catastrophe so is
the message getting through to people
how difficult is it for people to work
out how they can personally help on
climate
kate
to you first you've been with greenpeace
since 2014 have you sensed a change in
the public mood
i have yes i think that over the last
few years we've seen that public the
public are much more interested in
climate change so much more concerned
about climate change and that's true i
think even now
uh while we're in the middle of a
pandemic where some people might said
actually climate change is going to go
on a back burner for a lot of people
actually what's happening is that the
climate emergency and tackling it is
still one of the top voting issues for
people we've seen loads of polling
coming out this year basically all
saying that the majority of people want
the government to be taking much more
climate action they want to be spending
a lot more money to make sure that the
crisis is taken seriously and that the
government actually acts like we're in a
climate crisis which we are as well as
obviously
dealing with the pandemic and
understanding that the two can actually
go hand in hand and that we should be
really making sure that we're we've got
a green recovery coming out of the
covert pandemic
that's what people are really interested
in now
yeah very interesting and stewart your
thoughts on that typically people
wouldn't care about global issues in the
middle of a recession are you sensing a
change too in terms of what people care
about and what you're hearing within the
farming industry and agriculture
i i absolutely am i think people see
this as a as an opportunity to to take
stock to change things and i think as
kate says this green recovery point if i
look at the farming industry itself over
the last three four five years as we've
been starting to talk about net zero as
an industry farmers are really feeling
empowered they feel as though they can
be part of that solution and that
empowerment i think is really important
but it's also important i think at every
life stage so one of the most exciting
things we've been doing is actually
doing some stem uh projects in
classrooms with kids uh and actually
getting them to see where agriculture
butts up against and can be a solution
to climate change getting youngsters
involved getting everyone involved and
ultimately for me it's about empowering
every single one of us as an individual
to be part of that solution
and actually it's just part of our
everyday life doing something every day
to do our bit for the planet
and kate there's far more information
and dialogue now around about climate
change but many people are quite a high
proportion of people find it quite
confusing what they're reading on social
media of course mp's debating today
educating students on climate issues but
do you think they should be focusing on
other generations as well
i think honestly i do think that climate
information needs to be very clear very
accessible and it's what i spend quite a
lot of my time thinking about
um so that we can inspire everybody to
get involved and to do their bit whether
that's signing petitions whether that's
getting involved in local air pollution
campaigns whether that's writing to
their mps obviously we've seen it the
future generation of school strikers
have been hugely inspiring in terms of
what they've been doing and the protests
that they've been holding and so i think
that there is a huge amount of work to
be done still to make sure that the
information is getting out there so that
people can really understand it and know
what needs to be done